[Applaudissements]
bonjour moi c'est José garage Citroën de
Bois-d'Arcy garage de l'autoroute nous
allons regarder aujourd'hui les
contrôles à faire éventuels avant chaque
départ de
pour les vacances
[Musique]
donc je vais vous montrer les deux trois
petits contrôles à effectuer avant avant
les départs c'est toujours mieux donc on
va contrôler un petit niveau d'huile le
mieux c'est d'attendre moteur froid ou
quand le moteur est chaud de patienter 5
10 minutes pour que l'huile de
redescende dans la cuve donc on peut un
petit aller-retour surtout ne pas
dépasser le max qu'on soit entre les
deux c'est parfait ni en dessous du mini
ni au dessus du Maxi voilà pour le
niveau d'huile
après nous avons le liquide de
refroidissement qui a le bocal a évité
d'ouvrir moteur chaud risque c'est sous
pression pareil nous avons la même chose
que le niveau de le niveau d'huile nous
avons un traçage minimum un traçage
maximum là on voit que le niveau de
liquide de refroidissement est
impeccable
ensuite nous avons le liquide de
lave-glace on le voit avec le petit
cycle de pare-brise là ça vous pouvez le
remplir au maximum aucun risque il y a
pas de problème donc on va contrôler que
le gicleur de lave-glace et les
essuie-glaces fonctionnent correctement
quand c'est possible on peut jeter un
œil sur le niveau de liquide de frein
donc c'est un peu plus difficile souvent
mais nous avons la même chose nous avons
un niveau minimum un niveau maximum si
vous voyez qu'il y a pas de liquide de
frein le mieux serait de se rapprocher
vers votre garagiste qui dit niveau trop
faible dit souvent plaquettes de frein
usées
nous avons vérifié l'éclairage donc on
va faire le tour du véhicule là j'ai mis
les feux de position on voit que c'est
allumé partout devant et derrière
et bon on va finir le contrôle par la
pression des pneumatiques la plaque
constructeur va nous donner la pression
pneumatique pour une utilisation dite
normale et la pression pneumatique une
utilisation chargée notamment pour les
départs en vacances
et donc pour l'usure du pneumatique nous
avons la bande de roulement et dans
chaque rainure nous avons un petit une
petite boursouflure qui va nous nous
montrer l'état du d'usure du pneumatique
donc dès que la bande de roulement
arrive au même niveau que les
boursouflures ça veut dire que le pneu
est à remplacer
l'utilité de faire ces petits contrôles
avant de prendre la route c'est déjà
d'être un peu plus serein sur sur votre
trajet afin de débuter tourisme de de
légères pannes éventuelle